celtics fans suspected of throwing
bottle at kyrie irving
charged with assault and battery first
of all suspected
it's on camera it's not suspected we saw
a new york post
the knucklehead fan accused of hurling a
water bottle at netstar kyrie irving
after sunday's playoff game against the
boston celtics
will be arraigned tuesday on one count
of assault and battery with a dangerous
weapon according to multiple reports
boston police said 21 year old cole
buckley of braintree massachusetts was
arrested at td garden after a witness
reported
he threw a dasani water bottle that
gazed the head of irving it's
unfortunate that sports has come this
kind of crossroads irving said
where you are seeing old ways come up
underlying racism and treating people
like they are human zoo
in a human zoo kevin durant added have
some respect for the game have some
respect for human beings
have some respect for yourself your
mother wouldn't be proud of you throwing
the water
at basketball players grow the f up and
enjoy the game it's bigger than you
sunday's instance was not the first
involving a fan during the playoffs a
fan was banned from the madison square
garden last week for spitting
at hawks guard trey young in game two of
the next game and the
wizards regard guard russell you know we
talked about popcorn so what are your
thoughts about all this stuff taking
place
you know just because they're preaching
about it doesn't mean it's going to go
away i was listening to the kevin durant
quotes and they act like their
their voice is going to make a
difference yeah there's x amount of
idiots out there that they don't give a
damn this has been going on for a week
now where it's been a big deal and it
happened
last night someone stormed the corner
and you know he was answering a dare
right he was drunk you could just see
that he was laughing by the time he got
onto the court
he knew he was going to be arrested
kyrie irving that's it did you guys
think the water bottle was full
i saw the video of it i couldn't tell if
that thing flying through the air was
half full
good question i i think it was by the
way
it has to have water water it has to
have weight in it yeah so
what kyrie irving did first though is he
wiped his feet on the logo not that that
warrants you know almost to be getting
clocked by a water bottle but you know
celtics fans are nuts i used to live in
boston i used to be the sports anchor at
fox in boston so i've been in the middle
of this i'll tell you fans are crazy
i'll tell you one story
the the patriots were playing the
vikings one game and there was a fan
from minnesota that went there and the
viking fans you know sometimes they wear
those hats that have the long horns kind
of that nordic thing it's just a thing
they wear
so this guy felt something tugging on
the back of his head so he reaches back
there to stop and the dude behind him
had a scissors and was cutting the
ponytail off
okay of the fake hat now here's the
problem the guy that was the vikings fan
was a world-class surgeon
this guy went through his tendons on his
finger and he was serious
his like surgery career was about over
so weird things have happened in the
stands
no that really really totally happened
unbelievable yeah
so this stuff does go on now here's the
problem the nba players
kyrie irving is the last one you want to
have this happen to because
he's going to talk about it every single
day he's going to turn it into this huge
thing where every nba player
has a target on them and they really
don't these things are being blown out
of proportion a little bit
because they've been happening one after
another after another but you know
they did the right thing by arresting
this guy i think to prove a point so
this dude
is gonna be in serious trouble i would
say that would be the only way to slow
this thing down but
there is a very very small percentage of
people that are so stupid
so idiotic and so brazen that it will
continue to happen just because they
don't care
so yeah good point they they um by the
way if you're watching this i'm curious
comment below what you what you think
about what's taking place
do you have a unique opposing view or
anything else on what happened with the
nba
and all these fans that are upset with
them go ahead adam so they're clearly
going to make an example out of this guy
in boston
i mean they're they're they're charging
him with throwing a dangerous
weapon it was a water bottle here right
so do you think that's the right move to
charge they're making an example sure so
i mean salt and battery yeah but do you
think that's a good idea
i think they do i think that throwing a
water bottle at somebody is a
dangerous weapon no it's a good idea
that they're yes they are making an
example of
them they're basically saying if you're
going to do this kind of crap be
prepared to pay the
yes i do um but it is a slippery slope
all right now you threw popcorn on
somebody now you're getting arrested for
a popcorn
uh i think by far and away the worst
thing that happened was someone
spit on trey young keep in mind we're
living still living in covid
you know times right now that's
absolutely ridiculous to me what means
you're spitting on a plane and the guy
the guy just gets
banned from a knicks game yeah and he's
the mo one of the most likable players
in the nba what are you doing
what are you doing spinning on a player
what are you doing on anybody yeah
so i'm sorry go ahead but it's almost
like people
haven't been out for a year and they
forget how to act because that's
literally what happened here
but i think a bigger
story here is that when you think
nobody's watching you think you can act
tough
it's sort of the drake's famous line
uh trigger fingers turn to twitter
fingers it's sort of like your keyboard
warriors
and if you're in the masses and oh no
one's gonna see it let me just talk
let me spit on somebody let me throw a
water bottle no one's going to see it
but the problem is that you're
forgetting is there's cameras everywhere
everything you do on social media
everything you do
period is going to get caught so
uh charles barkley had a pretty good
recommendation he goes
this punk ass take him down to the
locker room and let him have a
one-on-one conversation with kyrie
let me know what happens with this guy
in boston right so that's
obviously charles barkey the the other
side
of the coin here is that talk about
level of pettiness is how petty can we
go here because
kyrie obviously he'll turn anything into
a racial issue
none of this to me is anything racial
whatsoever these are just idiot fans
doing
idiot things with indian idiot
tendencies but
now the celtics fan base have started a
petition
talk about pettiness to charge
kyrie with aggravated assault because in
he threw a basketball into the stands
when he was upset he threw a ball
so now you know how many time fans do
you think that's good
phenomenal to throw to charge guys
absolutely
why i mean i'm gonna tell you exactly
what let me let me tell you
um it's sun it's monday when do we do
jennifer's baby shower what's this we
said
we did a sunday okay we're at the house
okay everybody's up there you know
you're you're trying to change the
diaper which we realize if you haven't
seen
i mean if we pull up adam's video do you
have adam's video with adam try to uh to
put the clothes on of this kid
uh uh if you don't have it do you have
it you can pull it up and i made it for
hire to change yeah he's not but you
know but here's the thing what i liked
about it is you were so proud of
yourself
i thought i did it
what do you mean mario beat me i'm done
and it's like this
is not wrapped up you know the buttons
on the bottom you got to put by the
diapers he didn't put that up i would
imagine he mummified the baby
right i mean she could have seen like
somebody taping an ankle it was a proud
it's like nick young when he shot it he
turned around he held the three up
as if he made it and didn't go on that
was happening he just kind of held it
through i learned i learned when
changing a baby it's
uh with a as an adult you put if you're
if you put your underwear on first
that's first right
you put your pants on or your shirt on
first what do you do well for the baby
you get no no no no no for you
oh but this is a dance on her shirt this
is a baby buddy i'm not talking about
let me make you want to talk about that
baby
let me make sure you're saying with the
baby you put the shirt on first then the
pants aren't like
i did i had a bag already i have a baby
so we can get trained on this i'm
working on it okay all right so let me
get a lot of practice let me let me let
me give you this part here on what
happened so
we're smack talking everybody's talking
trash to each other okay when you talk
trash what happens you just have to be
ready can when you talk and trust so
dylan starts talking
to rob yeah they love my son it's like i
pick
you know such and such to beat donnie
the people
the baby laundry folding competition so
afterwards
rob wins and rob looks at dylan he says
so
you picked donny to beat me huh i won
and he says
give me one of these and dylan didn't no
he
reacted very negatively furious he's
like i'm not giving he just sat down the
corner i said come on i got to tell you
he had that look on his face that's the
coming i got to talk to so he comes and
sits next to me
and i'm whispering to him here's what i
told him i said listen dylan here's how
life works
okay if you don't want people to talk
trash to you
don't talk trash if you don't want
people to take shots at you don't take
shots
if you don't want people to really kill
you don't really kill them
if you don't want if you don't want that
don't say anything right but the moment
you do
you have to be ready to know that that
person could say something back to you
and if you do you have a couple choices
try to say nothing or you go back and it
could go back and forth constantly
but that's a choice you got to make i
said on one end i'm glad you're not
afraid but on the second hand i got i
want you to be ready that this can
happen
right what's the moral of the story
kyrie irving is dylan
that's simple kyrie irving is dylan he's
a baby
is what he is ever the question that
nobody's asking yesterday espn posted
something i wish i could go on my
instagram to take a look at this
kyrie irving is a seven-year-old boy
right now okay
i posted on instagram when the picture
when they posted a picture of all the
people that i ran into the floor spit or
done everything right i posted a
question i said
uh all of this is pathetic but can we
ask the one question
why are fans so upset at nba players why
or is that an off-limit
question and then boom it went off with
commentary
you know let me guess you're going to
say it's covet it's this it's not it's
not that big of a deal
it is that big of a deal here's why why
are the fans upset
why are they doing this why is it all of
a sudden let me get this straight
you can go for a team that you played
who paid you
you can go take your shoes and smear
your shoe
on the leprechaun after you won the game
assuming no one's going to see it
what the hell you think is going to
happen these are the kids that
you did not see this he goes at the end
of the game so imagine this is the
celtics logo with the leprechaun the
leprechaun
he puts his shoe down and he goes like
this on the leprechaun kind of like when
tyrell always
did that to the leprechaun then you have
this 21 year old kid who probably grew
up watching the celtics with his dad and
his mom
screaming at the screen being a doc
cause you know how celtics fans are die
hard
he's gonna take it personal there's a
part of me
that i like a fan defending what he
stands for to the point of throwing a
water bottle
absolutely not that's not acceptable but
listen kyrie
why are they upset at you maybe you've
been rubbing it in their face for the
last 12 months that everybody out there
that disagrees with you is racist
and they're sick of it they're just
absolutely sick of your
unnecessary comments that you're making
and you are sitting here acting like
you don't understand you know i'm just
life is tough you know it's really
tough right now and you know i'm just
you know i have to deal with certain
things i want to go away and play
not play a few games and the team has to
pay 20 million bucks every year nobody
knows where the hell you even duran says
i don't know where you are
oh but you can go out there and smear on
the thing i don't know about that now on
the westbrook side
here's the one thing about westbrook
westbrook plays hard and i don't like
when happened that one time when the
guys were flipping them off when he was
you know you know by the sidelines when
i don't know this was like four years
ago
okay i'll get into it with fans all the
time i'm a westbrook fan and i think
westbrook is a dog and i think the
league unfortunately is not gonna have a
lot of guys like that he's one of a kind
he's in a league of his own with the
people that are fighting he just broke
the triple double
record but the question is why are
people upset you know what happened with
kwame brown this last weekend
i don't know if you guys have been
following the last two weeks what's
going on what do you think about what's
going on with kwame what do you think
about what's going on
he posted something on social media what
exactly did he say i forgot the
number one pick he called out steven a
he called that charlemagne god he called
out
stephen jackson he called out everybody
yeah i remember reading that thing yeah
he wasn't very articulate
yeah yeah he has no credibility who
doesn't well let me tell you what he did
say which i like i tell you what he did
says which i like so
he went out there and he said about the
fact that
hey just because i posted something and
i said look at this candice brown
uh uh video what are your thoughts about
it everybody thinks i'm racist
i'm just watching the candace brown
video candice owens candace owns video
right
i'm watching the candice owns and what
she has to say and people are calling me
who are you voting for
i'm voting for trump oh you're not
voting for biden what are you talking
about and i say give me his policies
which policies are you voting for biden
this guy's going that direction so then
he's saying for the last 13 years he
says
you guys are out there bashing me says
stephen a i was a 17 year old kid
working under michael jordan who was
talking trash to me 24 7.
i don't know how to handle seven you
know at 17 years old how to be having
somebody like that that's constantly
berating me right
kwame is pushing the envelope hardcore
stephen a smith makes a response video
oh i saw that i don't know if you saw
that one of course
did you see the results on the bottom
though how many likes and dislikes it
got i did not have you seen that kai can
you pull up that video on stephanie
smith
well he went in on kwame bradley
smith did not let anything i i know he's
no hose bar
go to go to youtube just go to youtube
and type in stephen a kwame brown
stephen a smith club that's fine kwame
is with a k
i think it's uh k-w-l-a k-w
there you go just talking about it just
go down right there top there you go
uh click on the first one but here's
what you got to do you got to do it in a
way where
it's going to play and it's going
to be uh you can't play so here's what i
want you to do okay we can't do that go
and look at it yourself uh kai look at
it yourself
on your phone and tell us how many likes
and dislikes it has
kwame brown responds to esp i want you
to tell me how many likes and dislikes
stephen a's
video has i don't know if you can do
that if you can't do that i'll do it
myself
yeah that's the only data i want he's
going to regret that video who is steven
a tell me why
because he's paid to be a commentator
and you have opinions
never played tell us can you say it on
the mic so everybody can hear you
yeah are we good yeah we can hear you go
okay uh so the video has
28 000 likes and 30 000 dislikes
28 000 likes and 30 000 dislikes which
means
most people didn't like what he had to
say if it was an election the dislikes
wins the election
okay on the video that's not the case
with stephen a so they're basically
they're saying
that he thinks he should not have said
it no because because the point is
here's a kid that came at 17 years old
you're expecting a 17 year old kid to
have all this pressure yesterday i got a
call from one of our guys
and we're having a conversation about
somebody that was dealing with anxiety
and pressure and blood pressure went up
right which is a real thing by the way
which is a real thing by the way
you're seeing what happened with the uh
uh naomi
you know dealing with the pressures of
the media all this other stuff and you
know how that handles this is one of the
reasons why you're gonna have so much
respect
for folks who run for office in their
70s you're talking about
clinton obama not obama trump
biden sanders these people are in their
60s 70s running with all the pressure
non-stop trash talking about you your
wife your
kids your i mean it's tough your husband
constantly they're built for that though
they've been doing it
not about their build for that at 17 you
maybe not
and kwame had to go through that at 17.
he was destroyed at 17 years old
here's a kid that played in the league
for 13 years made 65 million dollars you
tell me any human being that plays
has a job for 13 years make 65 million
dollars
and you trash them for having 13 years
65 million dollars of money you make
and they went after the guy so finally
he just pushed back he snapped him good
for him yeah
his podcast was blowing up by the way
kwame brown he grew up in the sticks i
mean he was not
exactly a mature young man not a guy you
want to piss off yeah that
yeah and imagine michael jordan the
pressure he was putting on that kid
because michael wanted to prove himself
as an owner
as a guy running the team because
frankly you know michael jordan
basically failed as an
owner and as a gm so far i think you
could make that argument so
you know he put his reputation on the
line by drafting kwame brown but
stephen a um i think maybe you know he
might regret that a little but he has no
choice
right he can't he works for disney he
has to turn this into
something where kwame has to be wrong
because
everything with them is a black and
white issue literally especially in the
nba right now and as far as kyrie irving
no chance of they win in the nba
championship because of him zero
even though they have most talent
they're not going to win because of him
the only guy that could get him to play
to his potential is lebron right and
tell me why no way they can win it
because of him because his mind is not
set on being a champion right now
he is set on being a victim and looking
up the next thing that he can complain
about and realizing how bad his life is
and he's got the security of the
contract and he's already won a title
i don't know if i go that far i'll go as
far as saying he's a terrible uh
uh player to represent your brand like i
wouldn't want him
representing a brand but i think uh a.d
just got hurt sons are not going to beat
him you know
uh uh utah it's not going to happen who
else you got on the
philadelphia joe you know what's coming
out of the easter egg
well philadelphia he got hurt what's his
name embiid got hurt you got milwaukee i
mean i just don't see it i think durant
is that good of a player
but but to go back to this to go back to
this this issue here that we're talking
about
um what the nba did last year
what the industry of comedy has done for
the last decade
what hollywood has done the last 30
years
what these what tech has done the last
decade
they're gonna pay a price for this i was
on an instagram live with
jordan belfor you know wolf of wall
street and he was
sharing his frustration i can't
understand what's going on you know i
don't even have a voice if i say
something just because i'm not
you know a democrat and i have an
opposing view they're coming after me
and they're sending all this
i said i said jordan that's not how life
works is what do you mean
i said you can't bully people for too
long
you just cannot do it hollywood's
bullied people yes and guess what
mistakes they've made you know who runs
hollywood you know what people don't
realize who runs hollywood
what what what ethnicity what chinese
yes and jewish and jewish do you realize
how jews are being treated right now in
america do you realize if if the jewish
community flips
what happens if the top five producers
in hollywood who are jewish flip to the
other side what happens all of a sudden
what are they going to say all of a
sudden do you know what happened to
comedy
comedy if you make fun of trump you have
a job if you make fun of biden god
forbid you don't have a job
comedy is all about on one side right
now it's not both sides i want to hear
both sides of comedy
i want to see somebody make fun of both
sides comedy you can't get up there and
talk about all the stuff that the left
is doing because god forbid if you call
them out
you're you'll be yeah and the same
thing's happening with the nba
and mlb has almost fallen forward with
manfred with what he's doing
but if nba's wondering why people are
pissed off at you
you disrespected half of america you
made half of america feel guilty for
crime they never committed you know how
ridiculous it is to be with somebody
that constantly makes you feel guilt
for something you never did imagine
you're dating somebody that constantly
blames you
for something you've never done how long
can you tolerate that
not very long that's what the mba is
doing exactly and i'm sorry i'm sorry
kyrie i i watched this guy
play he's ridiculous you know that pepsi
commercial
with with kyrie who comes and he dresses
like the old man in the movie
uncle drew dude you don't even know how
much i love this guy's game
you have no idea how much i love this
guy's game but you have divided america
and what you're getting i i'm what
you're getting right now
it's not as bad as you think it's gonna
get but here's the part
when a year ago people were saying why
are so many people protesting and
writing
well why do you think they're writing
maybe the black community is upset
you're right maybe they are upset i give
them credence why they're upset now
to go and loot and destroy businesses no
i'm not okay with that
but when the shoe flips and i were given
the other side why do you think
people on the other side upset at you do
you think they've run the numbers and
realize what's going to happen when some
of the money isn't flowing into the nba
anymore because that will happen very
shortly if it hasn't already and by the
way i like
why kyrie i liked him wiping his feet on
the logo i thought that was kind of
a little fu to the crowd whatever he
used to play their little
banter but then you can't have that
reaction when someone gets upset that
you did it but i thought it was kind of
funny he's kind of subtly just kind of
wipes
but it's okay if you do that i don't
care if you do that just be ready yeah
be ready if you do that if you hustle
off the court then you know
if that happens don't be upset if a
prideful
proud fan of the celtics retaliates
who's a 21 year old knucklehead
don't be surprised right okay and drunk
you cannot do that to folks who are data
so now
if if if the mba here's all here's all
i'm curious about we're going to go to
the next topic i'm sure some of you guys
that are listening to this you're like
you know but this isn't sports
this this isn't sports yeah this is but
it's it's sports impact on society
it's it's go ahead no i'm just saying
this this is this is pop culture
here's what i'm curious about adam this
is what i'm curious about tom
all i'm watching right now is to see how
adam silver responds
because that dictates the rest when the
nfl got
really ugly in 2017 is because of how
roger goodell responded to what
colin kaepernick i am so curious to know
how silver responds to this and you've
been very clear on
on what uh godel should have done he
should have called kaepernick into his
office and said look
person's upset give him a damn call what
are you upset about pretending that it
was just going to go away it was not
this
what are you upset about let's have a
conversation
what frustrates you let's get to it
let's address it and then we move on
yeah
not not this whole thing that's taking
place right now i think you could make
the argument though that
adam silver is the second most powerful
person in the nba behind lebron
i think lebron dictates so much of this
i mean i guarantee you
he is telling silver how to handle some
of these and he's involved in this in
some way or another
i'm sure of it i do agree with you on
the lebron uh does
sort of run the nba silver obviously the
commissioner he's there
i do disagree with you that there's a
zero percent chance that
uh there's just sorry in brooklyn not
happening dude they're they're actually
literally
literally the favorites to win the
championship with durant and hardin
now um and b just got hurt not to get
too basketbally yeah but they are
literally the favorite so to say they
have a zero percent chance is just
factually inadequate however the part
i'll give them credence to is
there are certain players that distract
you from the big goal
that create additional type of
distractions i don't mind you know how
sometimes uh coaches would go out there
and they would take the heat
but the heat would take pressure off the
players so players can just perform and
the coach would take the pressure
this is a different kind of pressure
this is unnecessary attention you bring
into the team
your team's becoming a target yeah
that's what kyrie is doing with okay not
smart
he's bringing unnecessary attention just
by getting a water bottle thrown at him
like if yes
if he didn't i mean if no one's going
through the water bottle about him
and he wouldn't have been no no no you
go smear the the logo
i'm not a fan of that well the the the
back story to that is
and not to get too kyried out here he's
had a
an emotional meltdown of a past few
years keep in mind he played for boston
he got ran out of town he basically say
take the year off
no why doesn't the nba say take you why
would the nba want him to take a year
off why wouldn't you want him to take a
year off
why what well exactly i don't think the
nba is going to come in and say kyrie
yeah take it easy buddy he's got a
contract his as a general manager what
i'm gonna say to him uh you're under
this much stress you're under this much
stress
life is down i think he literally took
20 games off this year no no take an
entire year off i don't think he's
trying to take an entire year because he
wants the money that's why
well everyone wants the money no but you
want the money without the freedom of
having to be responsible for the money
that's been paid to you
he got a responsibility so the fan that
bought a season ticket
of the nets what does he do the fan that
bought
a forty thousand dollar quartzite season
to defend about a ten thousand dollar
season ticket with his kids
for 41 games thirty-six there's there
were no fans this year
uh for the majority what does that fan
do what does that fan do who's saying
this guy's not playing
what does the fans do they want him to
play yeah but i mean they had durant
they didn't play half the season they
got hardened
that wasn't on the team half the season
and he hasn't played at the end of the
day i think they're just going to be
it's a playoff i think they're going to
do what they got to do in the playoffs
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye